[Applause]
[Music]
I'm nested with sin
reason that they may know why
Yura
where is the other apostate
clip her wings
[Music]
[Applause]
your uh demons are coming cut her down
she's one of them left
watch your backs
[Applause]
[Music]
those things
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death and I fear no evil because I'm
blind to it all in my mind my gun they
comfort me
[Music]
cuz I know I'll kill my enemies when
they come
surely goodness and mercy will follow me
all the days of my life and I will dwell
on this earth forevermore
said I walk beside the still waters and
they restore my soul but I can't walk on
the path of the right because I'm wrong
no I can't walk on the path of the right
come
[Music]
what are you doing kiddo you really
gonna go through with this
I'm gonna find and I'm gonna kill every
one of them
[Music]
you
[Music]
today's
[Music]
it's been almost a year since we have
announced last of us part two it's been
hard being quiet for so long but you
know in the meantime we've put out a
little game called Uncharted The Lost
Legacy and with that finally out there
and people playing it and enjoying it
the entire studio is now on the last of
us part two we're in full production
every game leverages all of what we
learned and all the technology we've
built on the previous titles so this is
definitely using all the tech all the
engine improvements we made of uncharted
4 and now we've had several years to
build whole new tech to increase the
fidelity even further of our game
so this is the next evolution of our
Naughty Dog engine as far as lighting as
far as our character pipeline how we do
muscle deformation rain effects even
like our facial performance is this
whole new rig and whole new pipeline so
we can get an even truer performance to
what we're capturing on stage and now we
want to give the fans a little something
more lifting the curtain a little bit on
the story for the Last of Us part two
where's the other apostate
clip her wings the last of us at its
heart is about Joel and Ellie and their
journey but it's also an ensemble piece
with all these other characters fitting
into that theme and this time I wanted
to focus on some of the other really
important characters you know last year
at the PlayStation experience we talked
about the theme of hate and how much of
this story revolves around that this you
could see in a lot of ways speaks to
that so instead of giving you an
adjacent puzzle piece about Ellie and
Joel's journey we want to go somewhere
else and give you some something else
and see how people make the connections
but as far as who these characters are
what their conflict is where this takes
place when this takes place we're going
to leave it up to the fans for them
[Music]
[Music]
please
you